from producer Tim Burton and replacement
director Joel Schumacher comes a Batman
movie that replaces the 80s gothic look
of the first two with the ecstasy silks
fever dream of the mid-90s yep this is
definitely the worst movie I've seen 30
times Batman Forever after human cure
song Tim Burton made Batman cool for the
mainstream then put too much kinky stuff
in the sequel to sell kids toys Warner
Brothers picture show Walker as the
pariah a director to push the franchise
in a more family-friendly direction
Batman but hey this is what we had to go
through to get knowing take it away Joe
can I persuade you to take a sandwich
with you sir I'll get drive-thru meat
Val Kilmer's unique take on Batman he's
not weird like Keaton charming like
Clooney intimidating like Bale swole
like Affleck or emotional like a human
but he does contribute one major unique
trait to the Batman legacy his mouth is
always open
I mean bats do eat bugs I guess that's
one way to catch him watch Batman
face-to-face a man with the power of not
being a threat half the time but there's
also the ones he wearing Riddler Jim
Carrey at the height of his powers
brings the same manic energy he brings
to his other roles okay while Tommy Lee
Jones makes the horrible choice to bring
the same manic energy as Jim Carrey
watch these two actors try to one-up
each other on camera while the real
drama was apparently going down off
screen he got up and hugged me and said
I hate you I really don't like you Wow
thrill as Batman faces his greatest
danger yet the only thing that could
actually stop him for good a therapist
dr. chase Meridian takes her place
alongside Vicki Bale as the latest bad
girl friend you'll never hear from again
she's got brains brawn and she's not
using either of them because all she
does is perv out on a stranger in a
rubber suit you are interesting well I
wish I could say that my interest in you
was purely professional
my please Midland I've imagined this
moment since I first saw you your eyes
your lips your body experience the bat
family grow bigger with Chris
O'Donnell's Robin who's lame origin
story of the Robin name that flew in
like around is still better than the
Dark Knight Rises you see using from
them Robin a witness a mid-twenties
actor who is best to play a cool teen
complete with cool motorcycle and
leather jacket giant 90s cool guy
earring and something no one will ever
make cool laundry karate holy try clean
only Batman this makes me want to drink
some bleach so witness the beginning of
the end of the original bat quadrilogy
that put nipples on the bat suit
launched Akiva Goldsman 's career and
cut out the insane subplot with a giant
bat but survives today by hanging on to
its three redeeming qualities the thumbs
up give the epic seal song and the fact
that no matter what you have to say it's
not as B as Batman and Robin
never leave the cave without starring
hello reddit I am actor and artist Val
Kilmer am a chewed-up starburst Jim
Carrey's the movie doctor girlfriend the
adult wonder didn't sign up for this the
world's craziest laser tag arena the
Batman yeah guy what's that girl
Batman feel then oh well Batman begins
to suck did anyone notice two faces
layer only works if he's facing one
direction but they're to rearrange the
furniture when he turns around breathe
sunflower three to the right four to the
left rainbow
450 I've been falling for 30 minutes
soup is just boneless cereal I think
that the Twilight Saga are the most
amazing beautiful movies ever made and I
would very much like to marry Edward
Cullen